ah
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
the [__] clouds are killing me pilot
to Bombardier I can't see my eyes are
red I cannot see
[Applause]
pilot to Bombardier [__] Saturday
morning you're sitting there thinking
what am I gonna do them I gotta go
[__] shop and I'm and I'm walk around
with these [__] animal [__] no you're
gonna go to Amazon you're gonna order
everything on there you're gonna sit
there smoking dope
maybe do 22 push-ups for a vet and
that's as good as it [__] gets you're
gonna walk around like some [__]
bumpy they're you know bumping into
people huh how much is this get the [__]
out of here it's sadly [__] xi a
[__] December well what will 14 days
away from the big day Jesus comes to
your house eats cookies whatever the
[__] happens Beto
you know we're here we're queer I gotta
take time out of my busy day to make
sure you [__] this adore perfect
but Joey what's with the chitter chatter
let's spark this [__] let's
finish you up the Skywalker I gotta take
a whip right to the [__] weed store
anyway and check up on these
[__] you know this guy walked
this tremendous I got some fish I got
some perennial Russian friend gave me
last night I got a block a hash for this
week that's gonna [__] kill you
[__] I'm even scared to smoke
out enough time for them alright enough
time [__] breathing you smoked a
blunt edge that goes your [__] only
got one long left at this point again
but who gives a [__] let's spark let's
relax and let's see what the [__] is
really going on
Oh thinking about bono jiu-jitsu the
sun's not out if the Sun was out I just
stay out here and do some kettlebells
get some vitamin D maybe jump a little
rope but I think I'm gonna go to jujitsu
get a good sweat I went yesterday hey
listen when I go to jujitsu I basically
gotta get beat up I got that [__]
knocked out of me yesterday choke yeah
but listen I keep going because one day
if I keep showing up and paying
attention that turns around I can't
stress this enough [__] every
[__] quits up to three weeks
do what anything you know never mind you
anything people just quit is it them
stick it out keep showing up shut your
mouth don't say to worry you don't know
nothing you don't know nothing
and that's it that's that we're here
we're family we're gonna talk about [__]
today I don't give a [__] about the
special today I don't give a [__] about
that it's all about you today and are
you gonna take care of you and make this
week coming the best [__] week do you
like everything about that how can I
make this coming up the best week of my
[__] mind what do i do what do i do
it luminate the [__] safety net all
right eliminate the safety there ain't
no safety net he's gonna go for it or
not
eliminate the safety then you want your
life to start [__] kicking ass get
that thing on the way you don't need
dick there ain't no safety when you got
heart and balls there ain't no safety
safety comes with heart and balls that's
what part of it is damn I'm [__] high
already
I gotta slow down a little bit let's
finish this [__] off here another one
bites the dust huh what do you got
[Applause]
it's very nice I like smoking Leawood
you [__] I know I'm a loser I
don't [__] it that you can't give a [__]
listen as long as you know it going in
that makes my you know I'm not coming in
here making believe I'm [__] Johnny
with that I am what I am
who gives a [__] you keep going I think
it all suck your dick at the end of the
day what do you say we do a little
[__] pipe over this perennial up all
the [__] morning like I should do but
this this this is the best part of my
[__] day and if you know anything
about me you look there's nobody here
there's nobody jumpin up and down this
is the gut and a good and [__] evil
[__] there's one Kajol brings it
and goes into deep thought about his
next [__] psychological diabolical
move there's a [__] of the diabolic
story let's just get down to smoke and I
write Joey shut the [__] up I come here
I get on periscope you give me a [__]
hippie I know I know
that's the one that's something okay
from time to time you got a sink a
[__] ship and for that [__] second
but the most important thing is we sent
this ship together good googly moogly
anyway it's Saturday the sun's starting
to creep out you know I love you
[__] were on my own
would you guys differently this week god
damn it I never thought that something
like this could happen so thank you from
the bottom of my heart if you know
anything about me I'm very thankful that
you guys made my dream complete this
week thank you very much you keep doing
what you're doing and I'll keep doing
what I'm doing and we'll meet the
[__] middle [__]
have a great Saturday uncle Joey loves
you it always [__] hard don't take
[__] from nobody and [__] them all [__]
em all that's how this one ends
[__] [__] you too bird